I started telling you last week about
this idea of the voyage to the
underworld and I want to tell you a
little bit more about that young in
particular conceptualized the voyage to
the underworld as a journey into the
unconscious and the unconscious for the
psychoanalyst is a place of fantasy and
dreams and implicit presupposition and
habit and that's all correct
you know we there is an unconscious and
it's perfectly reasonable to
conceptualize it that way that the big
difference I think between the
psychoanalyst and the later more
empirical scientists is that the
psychoanalyst sort of envisioned your
psyche as a place of living partial
personalities instead of cognitive
computational systems you know that they
took into account the fact that you're
alive and that the parts of you are
alive and you know there's a
neuroscientist named gives at Gaza Nick
I don't know how to say his name
Gaza nigga that's wrong is that
Gazzaniga yeah I think that's it anyways
he did some of the earliest experiments
on split brains and so sometimes if you
have intractable epilepsy which I
wouldn't recommend by the way one of the
surgical procedures for mediating its
negative effects is something called a
you cut the corpus callosum and it's a
very large number large structure in the
brain that connects the two separate
hemispheres and you know it's not
obvious why we have two separate
hemispheres although I'll tell you a
little bit about why I think it is but
anyways they do communicate and what
Gazzaniga demonstrated was that you
could tell one hemisphere or something
without the other one knowing that both
hemispheres were conscious and that the
consciousness was somewhat independent
that
really strange it's very interesting
very interesting readings reading you
know because it suggests that fragments
of ourselves you can think of you have
fragments of yourself within you that
are like low resolution representations
of you you know and that and the
psychoanalyst would think of those more
as they're kind of like they're kind of
like one-eyed Giants that might be a way
of thinking about it if you were
thinking about it in a fantastical way
so there's the angry you and you know
you all come in contact with the angry
you it's a rather rigid that's the first
thing you might say about it it's
impulsive and short-term it doesn't
think much about the past unless it's
bad things about whoever you're angry at
in which case it thinks about them a lot
it's not too concerned with long-term
future consequences and mostly it wants
to be right and you know when angry you
disappears and normal you assuming such
a thing exists reappears you can be
perfectly shocked about how angry you
behaved and in fact sometimes if angry
you really gets out of hand like it
might in a battle and the war it might
do things that you just can't imagine
that you would do and under those
circumstances you can reveal parts of
yourself to yourself that are so foreign
and so horrifying that it will leave you
with post-traumatic stress disorder
because it is the case that many but not
all people who suffer from
post-traumatic stress disorder
especially if it's battlefield related
get it because of something they did
rather than something they saw or
something that happened to them and
that's really we're thinking about you
know I mean there's a lot of weird
potential nested inside people and you
know you don't see it under normal
circumstances because the circumstances
are normal and part of the reason that
we like the circumstances to be normal
it's precisely so that we don't see
those parts of people we don't want to
see